[Music]
jeremy's in detroit
hey jeremy welcome to the ramsay show
well thanks a lot for taking my call
sure um so
what my wife might have been angsting
over a car purchased for a little bit
and kind of want to see what you think
but maybe
how much money do you enter um right now
we've got uh 25k emergency fund
80k liquid investments 60k in our kids
college fund great what are you talking
about spending on your car
um i would like a tesla model 3
performance it's a 65 000
car is that a used car now this this
would be new
are you are you have a million dollar
net worth 1.8 yep
okay um and what's your household income
so i make a 196k a year
like six buy the car pretty easy huh
well you have the money you have the
money it's a small percentage of your
income you have a net worth of two
million dollars it's a sixty five
thousand dollar car
okay you're not you're not buying it
you're not asking you're not buying a
250 000
lamborghini no no maybe in another
decade or two but well not
maybe another couple in a million in net
worth and you know but
but uh because you want your you want
your rolling stock anything with wheels
and motors totaled up to be less than
half your annual income and it is
yeah even with that i've got bonuses and
others and you obviously need to pay
cash for it because you called dave
freaking ramsey right
yes yep yeah it would come out of the
liquid and you don't buy a new car
unless you have over a million dollar
net worth and you do
ta-da you got a tesla congratulations
you don't get a lot of people calling
dave for permission to buy a tesla and
him saying go buy the car so
don't push your luck brother go buy the
tesla
quit asking questions to go buy the
tesla you know it's the guidelines
that's right i don't tell people to not
have a good life i tell them to get
their self in a position that they do
have a good life get the tesla
get the tesla i guess james cut that
it is a tesla but there's that but
this is the ramsey show